acte avec pedro brenas neto responsable
numérique à république souveraine
bonsoir pedro gonzalez neto merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors martine aubry n'est pas la seule
il ya aussi le maire de grenoble eric
piolle qui est réticent à ce déploiement
sans garanties sanitaires préalable anne
hidalgo et pierre hurmic le maire de
bordeaux écolos eux n'ont pas voulu de
ce moratoire quelle est selon vous la
bonne attitude à avoir face à ce
déploiement à la fin de l'année de la 5g
alors franchement en 2020 on à qui on
voit on dire un retour de
l'obscurantisme un peu partout c'est à
dire que le coc vide a révélé pourrait
dire ce côté anti science une partie de
la population et donc il est très à la
mode de taper sur tout ce qui est pas
forcément compréhensible par la majorité
de la population et de leur affublé et
dangers possibles et inimaginables on
connaît le problème des compteurs linky
on aimait qu'on va dire si on doit se
rappeler dans l'histoire par exemple
quand il eut le chemin de fer le train à
vapeur qu'on a augmenté la vitesse je
crois c'était pour passer à plus de 40
km heure il y avait des politiques qui
disait que ça allait créer des
commotions cérébrales et quand elle est
rentrée dans un tunnel les gens allaient
tomber dans les pommes
et donc depuis le telegraph les premiers
téléphones portables régulièrement on
nous dit attention cette nouvelle
technologie va en finir avec l'humanité
gens les faire on se rend compte que
c'est rarement le cas
mais ça crée une peur irrationnelle chez
les gens et je pense que c'est très
populiste de la part des des mères en
question de dire on va faire un
moratoire comme s'il était à l'écouté de
la population alors qu'ils savent très
bien que final le risque est minime mais
vous êtes spécialiste du numérique
également spécialiste politique 1a
république souveraine
on sent qu'il ya un côté kolola sur
laquait sur sur lequel surf également la
gauche aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
aussi un des arguments pour ce s'ériger
contre la 5g
alors il ya le même phénomène avec les
gens qui sont maintenant six vaccins
sous prétexte qu'ils auraient un danger
cercle l'argument écologique sur la 5g
il serait réel si les revendications
étaient claires et compréhensibles c'est
dire que aujourd'hui moi j'estime qui
effectivement la multiplication des
antennes est une stupidité affolante
puisqu'on pourrait très bien et on l'a
pour la question de la télévision avec
un seul opérateur qui diffuse pour tout
le monde
on pourrait très bien avoir des antennes
mutualisé par une entreprise publique à
l'image de ce qu'était de tdf pour
justement la télévision et qu'il ouvre
aux opérateurs et donc au lieu d'avoir
quatre antennes puisqu'on a quatre
opérateurs en france on aurait qu'une
seule antenne donc déjà là dessus au
niveau des émissions on serait bien en
dessous de ce qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on quadruples en fait le
volume alors qu'il ya pas forcément
nécessiter donc là-dessus effectivement
ça ce sera une vraie position ça
permettrait des économies d'énergie ça
permettait un vrai une vraie
planification aussi et on va dire une
mutualisation des investissements
mais non on préfère dire ouh là là c'est
dangereux
justement ça va parler à une en
particulier les mouvements qui sont de
plus en plus forte des croissants terre
de gens qui pensent qu'on doit revenir à
un mode de consommation
on va dire plus archaïques et plus
respectueux de l'environnement ce que
nous avons six canons n'est pas contre
justement repenser notre mode de
consommation
par contre il faut garder raison c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui si on supprime des
antennes 4g pour mettre des antennes 5g
le risque il est quand même minime et
surtout les gens oublient que dans notre
univers
les planètes rayonne des ondes partout
le soleil c'est que des ondes et donc il
ya des particules partout quand je vous
parle c'est une onde sonore
certes les raisons sont partout elles
font partie on va dire
intrinsèquement notre planète de l'avis
de tous est donc un tremblement terre
c'est des ondes aussi donc c'est vrai
que là dessus on va dire on veut créer
une peur irrationnelle sur les ambres
gens en particulier la technologie
on nous fait la même peur avec
intelligence artificielle on nous
présente des terminator qui vont venir
tous nous tuer et c'est un peu c'est un
peu triste mais c'est justement
c'est cohérent avec cette montée en
matière de l'obscurantisme un peu
partout et du recul malheureusement de
l'éducation qui fait que les gens ont de
plus en plus peur de ce qu'ils ne
connaissent pas et le problème c'est
qu'il n'ya pas vraiment d'étude d'impact
sur ses ondes sur sur l'être humain et
sur l'environnement est ce que le
rapport attendu justement sur sur ses
répercussions de la ss fera évoluer un
petit peu les mentalités vous pensez
lorsqu'on cesse sur les vrais dangers
des ondes c'est surtout effectivement si
votre tête est collée à un téléphone qui
aimait trop d'onde
en fait c'est pas les ondes en soit
c'est l'échauffement qui fait que ça
fait cuire votre tête
donc c'est la même chose que si vous
passiez votre temps avec une tête collée
au micro ondes
ça fait un peu le même effet et de ce
point de vue là effectivement c'est
dangereux
maintenant on peut faire tous les
rapports convenable il faut pas me
auprès des antennes c'est ça exactement
mais en gros si on amasse a peut-être
coller à l'antenne à dire quand on a une
dizaine de mètres déjà l'effet n'est
plus là c'est surtout on va dire la
radiation mais on a le même problème que
les ordinateurs les personnes qui sont
mal voyantes et qui sont obligés d'être
très très proche des ordinateurs ont
souvent le visage brûlé par leur part
l'écran de l'ordinateur par le
rayonnement est là dessus c'est quelque
chose on va dire de physique
c'est dès qu'un appareil électrique
rayonne et mène la chaleur bah oui on
finit par fuir les traits et ça c'est la
réalité traitement on a on n'a pas de
recul et même une étude sur un mois deux
ans trois ans il faut des études sur du
long terme et on n'a pas ça donc
effectivement on a en a mais pas encore
d'études sur les premiers réseaux de
téléphone pour savoir les effets réels
que salue donc je suis très dubitatif du
fait qu'on soit capable de produire des
études qualitatives
c'est indiscutable sur ce sujet lille
qui sait de la résistance au risque de
prendre du retard puisque les autres
villes iront plus vite en la matière ça
risque d'être préjudiciable pour la
ville alors concrètement je pense pas
parce que on va être très sincère mais
la kadji actuelle est largement
suffisante pour les usages mobiles des
gens la 5g
c'est aussi un peu l'obsolescence
programmée un peu comme la 4k pour la
télé etc
c'est un moyen
pour les gens de renouveler leur parc de
téléphones lusage dès lors qu'on a
dépassé la 3g était largement suffisant
puisque ce qu'est ce que les gens font
aujourd'hui avec leur téléphone ils vont
sur facebook qui vont sur youtube etc
avoir une seconde de moins de
chargements du flux instagram de ses
amis je suis pas sûr que ça fasse une
grosse différence sur le commun des
mortels merci beaucoup pedro gonesse
neto d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur
rt france